also today if you are looking to spice
things up
ex burlesque is back and seducing
audiences with a special and
safe vip experience at the flamingo
rocky is live ready to give us the info
and a little show hey rocky
hey guys i can't help but just dance and
do this right because
there's some burlesque music on and we
are at the flamingo
for ex burlesque and we're always so
excited to tell people that there's a
new show
opening up or it's not new it's been
it's been around for two decades but
it's coming back to the strip
so caroline laura thank you for joining
me caroline tell us what we can expect
at x burlesque so when you come over to
experlesque we have a private edition
going on right now due to the covert
situation
so for 199 including taxes and fees
you're going to get your own table
with some champagne socially distant so
you can enjoy
us as a private edition with just 30
other tables so that's
that's it just as and you can have a
question and answer at the end of the
show too
i like this so it's very intimate and
laura what can we expect on stage from
you guys
oh well you can expect a good show
that's for sure
we dance really hard and we have a lot
of costume changes we have a variety of
acts and themes so everything you could
desire will be satisfied
and i love laura caroline i love you too
but laura you are six foot one
so am i so we decided that we need to
have a duet correct
yeah it's gonna be from chicago you know
and i can't do it alone
if you can do this she's home please
check her out this weekend oh my gosh
yes check me out this weekend and coming
up later in the show we're gonna have
them put on a show so you guys can get a
taste of what to expect here
but ex burlesque at the flamingo at the
expos theater
and it's it's only thursdays fridays and
saturdays right tuesday
night what time seven and 10 p.m ooh
10 p.m for the you know get you in the
mood what's your favorite song to kind
of get you in the burlesque mood
um probably a christina aguilera song
from the strip days that's the best
album for sure
there you go people i think you should
stick around for the show coming up i'll
send it back to you
thank you rocky we look forward to
checking back in with you later on in
our show
we're not going anywhere